[Music]
good afternoon my name is linda mustacky
i'm french
i would like to
wish all of you ladies and gentlemen
citizens of europe
a warm welcome to the
closing ceremony of the conference on
the future of europe
i participated in the european citizens
panel and in the european plenary
my daughter najis who is here today was
born during this conference just like
our hundreds of recommendations
exactly one year after the inaugural
ceremony of the conference it is an
honor for me alongside my fellow
citizens to accompany this historic
closing ceremony
it's a pleasure for me to officially
declare open the ceremony we'll begin
with uh dance lehop dance europe
say the lunar president
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
avec
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
h
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop
[Music]
bravia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
visage
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a spear
merciful addons
hello
hello
hello my name is gabriela hagenberg and
i'm from germany
like linda
i am a i've been a participant in one of
the european citizens panels and today
i'm celebrating my birthday with all of
you
[Applause]
my birthday is also europe day
and in future perhaps it will be a
public holiday for the whole of europe
for all europeans
it is a great pleasure for me
to be here at this solemn moment
my word for the conference is exciting
exciting because i was able to
contribute towards the citizens
recommendations and also because i have
made many european friends
the co-chairs of the executive board of
the conference are with us today here
each of them represents one of the three
institutions of the european union
they have worked closely together in
order to make
this process possible in the first place
so i give the floor now
to give hofstadt who is a member of the
european parliament
[Applause]
merci
thank you very much
presidents of the commission parliament
president of the republic prime minister
today
it's not us
but citizens
who are going to be handing over
the final report on the conference on
the future of europe
let me take this opportunity
to
thank
my
two
co-chairs for their co-op constructive
cooperation
it was a little bit
like a menage a trois
it was difficult
sometimes
frightening but always passionate
this report dear friends
contains 49
objectives
which have emerged from over 300
proposals and measures and all of these
are based
on the proposals of our citizens
and have also been adopted by the
plenary of the conference
these proposals i believe show us the
path
the european union should follow during
the coming decades
it'll
turn the union
more democratic more integrated a union
that can act
more rapidly and in a more decisive
manner when tackling the challenges of
tomorrow
this result has only been made possible
thanks to one thing
participation
the participation of our co-citizens and
on behalf of you all i'd like to
sincerely thank them for their active
participation and sincere commitment
[Applause]
libra
perspective
all citizens believe in the european
project but most people are also of the
opinion that the european union doesn't
currently fulfill their dream
so
they may well love europe but at the
same time they're hugely critical when
it comes to the working of the union
and sometimes i would say for good
reason
during this conference
is that in contrast
to what we think
people don't fair change
on the contrary
they urge us to reform the union
and they want this to happen now you
know when in 2019 the idea floated
of this conference
the world was a
very different place
from the world we are in today
since 2019 we have got a pandemic
affecting millions of people killing
hundreds of thousands of humans and now
77 years after the end of the second
world war
we have again a devastating war
on european soil the result of
brutal aggression
killing
thousands of civilian men women and
children alike
it's a war of illegal autocracy
against a liberal democracy a war of
russian brutality
against our european values
you look
let's tomorrow spot the difference
on the 9th of may of this day
in moscow
a parade
with a delirium of arms weapons and
tanks
and here in strasbourg
a festival
of citizens
with their european leaders expressing
their renewed fate in our common peace
project
that's the difference between this
and whatever the outcome of this
conflict of this war in ukraine will be
whatever my belief that liberal
democracy will ultimately prevail
the fact is
that the world of tomorrow will be a
different place
it will be a world dominated by empires
china russia india united states of
course well in such a world order
dear friends
only europe as a bloc
can survive
only united we can defend our values we
can protect the interests of all
citizens
because the european union
that acts too little too late as we have
seen so many times will not survive
and in that sense i have to tell you
that is my firm conviction european
integration is no longer a question of
choice
it has become a question of necessity
a question of survival
and the recommendations of the citizens
and the conclusions of the conference
offers i think as a road map to do that
to avoid that we become irrelevant
or even disappear
a new an effective
more democratic europe is possible
a europe that is sovereign
a europe that is capable to act any
europe that leads planet earth forward
and then my short final lesson
there is i think after this experience
no real opposition or contradiction
between representative and participatory
democracy and i say that here in the
where we do the representative democracy
on the contrary i think in a modern
democracy both are necessary and it's my
firm belief that beyond elections
we need
their citizens to institutionalize
direct citizens participation as an
antidote to division in society
and
an antidote
that is
urgently needed
against the democratic system that is
slowly dying under our eyes
as it is poisoned by the almighty
algorithms
of mr musk
and mr zuckerberg we see humans only as
prophets
and by state-sponsored russian hackers
or chinese bots who are treating
citizens in fact are social psychopaths
because that's what they do
so there is no time to waste
let's be loyal to the outcome of the
conference
let's implement its conclusions as soon
as possible because it's the will of the
people and let the will of the people
prevail thank you for your efforts thank
you
on behalf
of the french council presidency let me
now give the floor to minister clement
born
acting chairman of the conference please
[Applause]
of the republic prime minister ladies
and gentlemen ministers members
of parliaments co-chairs citizens
three years ago the conference on the
future of europe was a bit of a crazy
idea
a year ago
the conference
was launched here
and
now we can see that it's been a success
as ghee said
as
i'm sure
mrs switzer will say this conference
owes you
citizens everything your
some of the few
of the citizens who have been committed
you represent these tens of thousands
who got involved and the hundreds of
thousands
who made contributions online you've
been involved in long hours of work to
discuss debate reflect criticize and
make proposals on the future of europe
countless participants have been
represented by you and i'd like to thank
them and give them a round of applause
[Applause]
success
i think
this success is shown by the very
specific and clear 49 objectives
and the 300 clear measures that you have
patiently drawn up
you've drawn up a credible and ambitious
road map for all of us
you have created
a vision of europe for the decades to
come
a brave and protecting europe that takes
on a leading role in the climate and
environment that is more effective in
what it does and gives citizens their
place in decision making but this
conference is not only a success it is
first and foremost an example an example
for our europe
we have seen europe
move
forward when crises take place the
knights of of european council meetings
but you have shown that we can act
collectively and effectively
via patient discussion reasoned debate
by
placing our common values above specific
interests
this conference is first and foremost an
example for the world
today on the 9th of may
mr putin has decided to bring war to our
continent but at the same time you've
chosen democracy
i predict that
on the 9th of may history will recall
how in russia there were military
parades whereas here in strasbourg
hundreds of citizens came together to
refound
our euro our union and history will show
that we that you were right
citizens participants presidents
this success in this example
obliges
us
obliges our institutions to follow up on
these proposals to establish
priorities courageously without taboos
legislating always means making choices
and choices will have to be made
and we will make choices and we will
come back to you in a regular and
transparent manner to explain our
choices
citizens participants in the conference
we
are pleased to have been able to count
on you you can now count on us thank you
so
much
let me now give the floor to mrs
dubravka switzer vice president of the
european commission please
[Applause]
dear presidents distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen dear citizens
the suman declaration states that the
europe will be built on concrete
achievements and solidarity
this remains true today
europe is a journey
today we present the final report and
its 49 proposals of the conference on
the future of europe to the three
presidents
this report is built on trust and hope
for a better europe this conference
proves that it was the right choice to
put citizens at the heart of the process
we now start
delivering on your incredible work i
will work hard to ensure that we are
deserving of your trust
the conference requires courage and leap
of faith to deliberate on our future
because we have seized that opportunity
together european democracy will never
be the same again
a defining moment of my life
was croatia's accession to the union to
the european union
it is a privilege to me
as a crowd as a european
to lead the commission's work on the
conference
and we are doing this with the war in
ukraine raging on our continent
having personally witnessed vladivo i
cannot take this achievement in
deliberative democracy for granted
i know that this hemi cycle is the
center of european representative
democracy
but from now on i will truly miss the
contribution of citizens
because your participation enriches our
representative democracy and 49
proposals are proof of this
the conference kicked off in a pandemic
but you stayed with us you stuck with us
the european citizens panel took place
across the european union we were in
maastricht on the anniversary of the
treaty of the same name
then war broke out on european soil
at the panel in dublin
you citizens made a spontaneous stand
for ukraine
it was a touching moment of solidarity
our aim was to design a process to be as
inclusive and representative as possible
if this conference is a success it is
thanks to the contribution of the
broader spectrum of stakeholders civil
society citizens and social partners
i am aware that the conference was not
perfect but we adapted when necessary
and we have learned valuable lessons
the deliberative process laosa allows
our europe to grow it is a human and
democratic process
you may remember one mother
we already saw who spoke at the last
plenary with her new baby in her arms
some young citizens
were so motivated that one day they will
be politicians themselves i hope
the older and wiser ones they were proud
to build a brighter future for their
children and for their grandchildren
and
all of us were part of the emotional
standing ovation of a
acclamation ten years ago here in this
hemi cycle
there was skepticism at the beginning
but many skeptics were convinced by the
enthusiastic dedication of the citizens
thanks to our courage to come together
to deliberate on our common future
european democracy is forever changed
three european institutions
working together in a unique endeavor
and to conclude i will conclude with a
quote from one of you from one citizens
who said
read the proposals well and implement
them
we believe in it this is what citizens
told us
building the house of european democracy
and creating an ecosystem of democratic
citizens engagement requires belief a
trust a belief a trust in our european
values a belief in ourselves and each
other to build a democracy which is fit
for the future
dear all
i'm sure that our democracy is louder
than putin's bombs thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
the working group members agreed on the
need to take a climate change and on the
eu to continue to play the role of
global leader
and it is important to talk and debate
but wasting time is something we can no
longer afford
[Music]
the health of european citizens is not
something that has a value that can be
quantified a very strong feeling that
we could and we should do
if it comes to health much more at the
european union level and that we should
learn more from the pandemic
war is unexpectedly at the borders of
our union with significant humanitarian
and economic consequences
it's clear that we aspire to a common
vision which is that the european union
should be strong stable and united this
would allow it to offer a model to the
world and to defend its values which
would guarantee peace and international
cooperation
[Music]
people are still being left behind in
europe
this is not good enough on this we can
do better
[Music]
it's possible to reshape the european
union without exhausting or destroying
the framework of a renewed social
contract
[Music]
digital transformation concerns everyone
it helps us on a daily basis and will be
more and more present in our lives
demonstrate that the digital future it
can be human centered and the cyber
world
it can be designed to be trustworthy and
safe
[Music]
migration was is and will continue to be
part of the human condition citizens are
asking for fair
sharing of the migrant flows throughout
the eu member states easier application
and faster integration of asylum seekers
we focused on how to improve the
opportunities and realities
for young people to ensure that our
young generation can achieve their true
potential the younger generation
our young people have the right to live
in a world which is not destroyed by
famine and war
and we have to do the our utmost to make
this possible
[Music]
european democracy
european democracy needs to be
strengthened we need to breathe
fresh life into european democracy our
goal is to make the um understandable
accessible and strengthen our common
european identity on the message from
citizens which was clear that values and
rights are an absolute priority and are
at the absolute center of what it means
to be part of the european union and we
are ready to go and do
what's necessary
[Music]
this plenary has reached the consensus
on the proposals i therefore commend the
consensus to the plenary
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good
afternoon everybody
my name is matus pelolovic and i come
from the heart of europe from the czech
republic
the word that sums up this conference
for me is
new
new this has been something new from the
outset
the conference counted on the active
involvement of citizens citizens from
different corners of europe from
different origins who met to discuss
challenges that can change the way the
european union works
allow me now
to invite five of our citizens to share
their experiences with us
and to
tell us about some of the priorities
that we have recommended or which have
been added by the other components of
citizens jorge pazos from the canary
islands in spain
tilde carlson from sweden
jean-reggie de vance from france
casper parole from poland
and laura mariachin queenie from italy
so dear colleagues
you have the floor go ahead
[Applause]
macron
prime minister costa
ministers
members of the plenary of the conference
colleagues
panelists across europe
friends
in summary my dear europeans my name is
jorge pazos and it's my honor to be the
first citizen to take the floor today
i come from the canary islands
and throughout this whole process
i have felt extremely fortunate
to consider this hemicycle as a second
home
a home for all europeans and on behalf
of all of the panelists here those
attending in person those attending
remotely
allow me to start by thanking the
european parliament the council and the
commission for giving us the opportunity
to be involved in reforming europe
we have got to know citizens from every
country of europe politicians people
working in the social sphere extending
our horizons
we've grown as europeans
and for this to happen we've made
sacrifices we have put our lives on hold
we've taken holiday days from our work
and
when it comes to the european citizens
panel we've spent nine weekends away
from our families
without a doubt it's been a magnifice
magnificent experience
there were difficulties in our path
we didn't always get clear answers
we know
that the proposals will not be
implemented overnight but we have trust
that you will do everything necessary to
ensure they are implemented
through respect for the work we've done
but also through respect for all
europeans
if we as citizens
have been capable
of working together
and to reach a consensus you can and
must do the same
all of us have been on a long journey
and now that the work in plenary has
come to an end i think we can be proud
of what we've achieved
we will be
presenting you with eight horizontal
subjects
which
provide an optimistic and clear mandate
for europe and now i'd like to pass the
floor to my colleague tilde
hey
good
morning my name is tilda i come from
sweden from a small village
and i would like to
present three priorities to you
which all of the citizens here have
agreed upon and which are close to our
heart the first priority is europe
that's based on solidarity social
justice and equality
what's important for citizens
is that there are equal rights across
the board in terms of health medical
care
education lifelong learning the same
possibilities for people living in rural
areas as for those living in towns and
cities
to take into account the differences
that exist in geographical terms and
demographic terms there should be no
discrimination based on age residents
nationality sex religion or political
preferences
instead
citizens should have living conditions
working conditions which are decent and
salaries that are decent europe is more
than an economic union the member states
should be showing more solidarity to
each other we're a family and we should
be
behaving as such in times of crisis
secondly the european union needs to be
audacious and act rapidly to become a
world leader in the field of environment
and the climate by speeding up the green
transition
improving railways
providing sustainable transport and a
genuinely circular economy there is no
time to lose
changes are necessary in
numerous areas agriculture biodiversity
the economy energy transport education
health
the digital transition
and climate diplomacy
we have a great deal of research
capacity
we can do this if climate becomes a
priority
then we can also expect a prosperous
future
thirdly
you asked us
for help you asked us
how we can ensure that we can shore up
democracy in europe in the future and
we've answered we want to be able to act
in crises
rapidly
and the principle of unanimous unanimity
needs to be rethought and you need more
involvement of citizens thank you very
much i'd like to pass the floor now to
my colleague
jean-registered
[Applause]
and i've been fortunate enough to be a
part of this adventure i'm 78 years old
i live in a lovely village in normandy
these are the priorities for european
citizens a strong europe in the world
where we are more united than ever where
the european union is given competences
in the field of foreign affairs this
conference could be at the basis of more
united europe
more consistent europe in political
terms more coherent
everything can be summarized in one word
union
it's an imperative that we provide
ourselves with the resources to be able
to overcome this challenge
the war that is knocking on our doors to
the east shows how important this is
a europe that's economically autonomous
to ensure its competitiveness in the
world we have to achieve this goal
in strategic key sectors agriculture
energy industry health
for that to happen
we have to avoid dependency on third
countries for numerous sensitive
products
let's
in fact encourage the talent of our
citizens and avoid a brain drain
europe supports fundamental values and
principles and the current war shows how
fragile our democracies can be this
fight for freedom is something that
never should be forgotten throughout the
whole of this process we've reiterated
these fundamental values
that we need to provide a dignified
welcome to refugees and immigrants
proper health care fighting against
corruption
protecting nature and biodiversity and
that this should be cross-cutting and a
more democratic union too
apart from what tilde has already said
on the environment in the film the day
after tomorrow that came out of 2004 a
climate skeptic who had to migrate
following a climate disaster said
we all felt a huge amount of humility
when faced with the destructive force of
nature
numerous people
are now
actually refugees in what was called the
third world we needed them they allowed
us to come into their lands they
welcomed us
i'd now like to pass the floor to casper
paddle
[Applause]
my name is casper parrot and i'm 23
years old i come from guniezno the first
capital of poland
i love my country poland which is why
exactly one year ago together with other
young people i founded the impulse
foundation which supports the
participation of the young generation in
public life
we the young want to be heard so that we
can fight for our future and our future
is here in the european union
unfortunately we live in a world of
increasing threats the tragic war in
ukraine a terrifying climate crisis
the foundations of democracy under
attack
we must stand together the four together
let us build a european identity
that is resilient and resistant to
everything an identity that complements
but does not replace our national
identities
many of the people i met here at this
conference did not feel european
today
with time we can all say together we are
the citizens of europe
we need to further increase our
influence in the european union we need
to open up new horizons
we need more mobility more exchanges
more education we need more europe
and today more than ever before we need
to empower young people
it was decided to invite 16 year olds to
this conference
and we are very grateful for this it's a
very good starting point
but we need more
we the young
feel that we are underrepresented
we are excluded from the decision-making
process we are not being had when we
talk about our problems
about
how hard it is to become independent uh
about how how hard it is to find housing
about in either inadequate education
about discrimination against sexual
minorities in many countries
and the crisis in mental health
they do not
listen to us when we talk that the
inadequate action on the climate crisis
is stealing our future
the war in the ukraine has the same
source as the climate crisis
and the sources fossil fuel
that fuels uh
that fuels conflict if we stick with
fossil fuels we will finance the war we
should give up fossil fuels
let's act together let's impose total
embargo
[Applause]
and
still i'm full of hope here in this
chamber the young people are being heard
this voice should be heard every day in
every corner of the european union
leadership is where young people have a
say for their future it's a great
opportunity let it not go to waste
thank you very much and now
i hand over
to laura mariachini
[Music]
[Applause]
23 years old today i am concluding the
speeches of citizens by stressing an
important point
at the start nobody knew
what the result of this conference would
be
the result
of an event
bringing together more than 800 citizens
from
the whole of europe different age
citizens speaking different languages
having different experiences of life
apart from the initial doubts this
diversity was not an obstacle on the
contrary
as we got to work
we
connected with each other
we entered into a kind of
sync
because we're not experts on the
subjects of the conference or experts in
european politics but we are experts in
real life
we go to work
we live in the countryside in towns we
do night shifts we study we have
children we take public transport
in summary
we
understand
the ordinary problems experienced by
ordinary people
being asked to get to work
we've used the experience of our own
lives and we rolled up our sleeves
and we managed to reach agreement
on proposals for genuine
qualitative changes
of course we could have done with more
time to perfect our work
and i would repeat we're not
professional politicians
but we are satisfied
what we are now handing over to you
is the fruit of months of sacrifice and
dedication
and as such should be respected
we therefore call on you to very
carefully read all of our proposals and
to implement all of them
without distorting them
without
being selective depending on your
political agendas or interests
without limiting yourselves to those
proposals that don't require treaty
change
these proposals we are presenting you
with
outline a new europe
a europe that we believe in
and europe that we will continue to
fight for
a europe which we need now
please don't waste this opportunity and
don't delude yourselves or disappoint us
because never have we felt more united
more european and more trustful in a
better future than we do now thank you
[Applause]
thank you my dear colleagues
thank you once again my name is peter
chakai shakir from hungary and the word
i've chosen is camaraderie
we arrived here at a particular point in
the conference
and now i'd like to ask the presidents
of the european
the three co-presidents of the
conference and citizens to stand to
receive the report of the conference
this report contains 49 recommendations
with 300 concrete actions based on the
suggestions from citizens
they've been debated by the 449 members
of the plenary
and will be handed to the presidents of
the three european institutions we're
now going to have a family photo and i
would like all of us to be included in
it thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
and this is uh the report on the
conference which we'll be able to see
online
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Applause]
do
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello
my name is caterina rende dominus
i come from beautiful croatia
i have had the honor to represent
national events in croatia i am 25
and my family comes from two european
nations
for me and my family europe stands for
being united and
for freedom and for a single european
identity i work and volunteer for the
association youth in the eu which
operates from shibanik a small and
charming city on the adriatic coast
the word i have chosen that for me would
best represent the experience of the
conference is together because this
conference is a proof that eu
institutions and citizens can jointly
create a better future and that we are
all citizens
with a common goal of improvement
we have just uh enjoyed the sounds of
the european hymn
the ode to joy by
uh bethoven performed by young artists
from all over europe demos europe
orchestra is a string orchestra
initiated as an inclusion project by the
paris philharmonic orchestra during the
french presidency of the eu
they are here with us as an example
that art and music have no borders
music has the magical power of uniting
us
in the emotional enjoyment of its beauty
so i would like us to
welcome once again demos europe
orchestra which will now perform
vivaldi's lestro and monaco number three
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
i am susana hoslerova
i'm a 22 year old student of european
studies and of the half
from a small place in slovakia a town
called nove zamke
i'm extremely honored to have been able
to represent slovak citizens at the
conference on the future of europe
at national panels and events
i also wanted to share with you a word
which for me symbolizes the spirit of
the conference
but i must admit that over the past year
after everything we have experienced
here i've been speechless
and the only feeling i'm carrying along
home is gratitude
the presidents of the three institutions
together with four
citizens representing european civil
panels will now be addressing you
roberta mitzola
president of the european uh parliament
will address you will be the first
speaker the floor is yours
madam masala
[Applause]
thank you thank you susanna
president van der lyon president macron
prime minister
costa dear
europeans
i am so proud to be here today
as we come to this milestone in this
unique exercise in active citizenship
in europe building
in future proofing
our foundations
among the many speeches we hear
today i think there is one
message that we can take away today
europe's future
is yet
unwritten
and our story depends
on you
on all of us
this debate took on a new reality
on february 24th
when president putin ordered his army
to invade ukraine
an act of medieval aggression
that has changed the world
the post february 24th world is a very
different one
a more dangerous one and europe's role
has changed with it
we cannot afford to lose any more time
how we have responded
to the invasion
and how we must continue to respond
is the litmus test
of our values
the unity
and resolve of our response has
confounded critics and made us proud
to be european
that must be the blueprint going forward
but as we speak here
ukraine
is still
being invaded
bombs
are still killing
indiscriminately
women
are still
being raped
millions have fled
and will continue to do so
people are still trapped
in the tunnels under mariupol
and ukrainians look to europe
for support because they know
that millions and what millions of
europeans
who were forced to spend half a century
behind the yoke
of the iron curtain will tell you
there is no alternative to europe
the future of europe is tied to the
future of ukraine
the threat that we face
is real
and the cost of failure
is momentous
and i ask
how will history judge
our actions
will future generations read about the
triumph of
multilateralism over
isolationism
the cementing of an interdependent
relationship between nations and people
who are proud of their differences as
laura said earlier but who understand
that in this new world the future can
only be together
that
is all up to us
that is our responsibility
and let me tell you here today
that the european parliament will fight
for a stronger europe and all of what
europe means
and that means freedom
it means democracy
means the rule of law
it means justice
solidarity
equality of opportunity
and that means that we must listen
more than we speak
and this exercise must be
about you
about our project
working for people and villages and
towns and regions across europe
europe has a proud history
we have created
the common market ensured
enlargement to successive states
embraced
universal suffrage eliminated internal
borders
created a common currency and enshrined
fundamental rights into our treaties
our european project has been
a success story may not be perfect but
we represent a bastion of liberal
democracy of personal freedoms of
liberty of thought of safety and
security and that is what inspires
millions and millions of people in
europe and around the world
however this conference also proves that
there exists a gap
between what people expect
and what people
and what europe is able to deliver
at the moment
and that is why we need a convention as
the next step and that is what the
european parliament will insist on
[Applause]
there are issues that simply cannot wait
that is true for defense we need a new
security and defense policy because we
know that we need each other that alone
we are vulnerable
and here we don't have to reinvent the
wheel we can complement rather than
compete with existing alliances
it is true for energy
we are still
too reliant on autocrats
where energy islands still exist
where we must support each other as we
disentangle ourselves from the kremlin
and invest in alternative energy sources
where we understand
that renewable energy is as much about
security as it is about the environment
but we can only do that together
we can only do that together
this is also true
for climate change
the challenge of a generation that
europe has proudly led
the global charge on
it is true for health
where we must heed the lessons of the
pandemic
and make our health systems
interconnected
share information and pool resources
when the next virus hits us we cannot
let it shut down our lives
our first instinct cannot be to recreate
the borders of the past
[Applause]
it is true for our economic model
where we must ensure enough flexibility
without tying the hands for generations
to come
where we are able to create jobs
and the jobs that we need to thrive
it is true for migration as we heard in
the videos and the testimonies where we
still need a system that is fair
with those who are in need of protection
that is firm
with those who are not but that is
strong
against those who abuse
the most vulnerable people on the planet
it is true
for equality and solidarity
our europe must remain a place where you
can be who you wish to be
where your potential is not impacted by
your birthplace your gender or sexual
orientation
a europe that stands up for our rights
for women for minorities for us all a
europe that leaves nobody nobody behind
in all these areas and more
i want europe to lead
because if it is not us
it will simply be someone else
dear europeans
this conference on the future of europe
involved hundreds of thousands of people
across europe
this has been an intense experience in
the power of participatory democracy
after months of discussions and powerful
debates
i want to thank you
for believing in the promise of europe
and i want to specifically thank
giver hofstadt and dubravka switzerland
the different presidencies of the
council prime minister costa minister
clement here today thank you for leading
the process thank you
[Applause]
i also want to thank
our late president
david zasoli
who would be so proud
[Applause]
he would be so proud today
and of course
nothing of none of this could have been
done
without all the stuff and i ask you
please to applaud the staff of the
european parliament and the institutions
who really really worked
for this to happen
i thank you all
for believing in this exercise
for fighting for europe
for facing down
the cynics it is easier
to be cynical to be populist to look
inwards
but we should expose
populism
cynicism and nationalism for what they
are
false hope
sold by those with no answers
those who are afraid to forge the hard
and long road of progress
ladies and gentlemen
europe has never been afraid and now it
is time to step up
and not step back
we are once again at a defining moment
of european integration and no
suggestion for change should be off
limits
whatever process is required in order
for us to get there should be embraced
as a student i got involved in politics
because i believed my generation's place
was europe
i believe this still
we see no old and no new europe
we see no big and no small states
we understand that ideas are bigger than
geography
that feeling 18 years ago
when 10 countries including my own join
the european union is a moment that will
remain with me forever we counted the
seconds to midnight on may day and you
could feel the joy the hope
the passion with which people believed
people today in ukraine
in georgia
in moldova and still in the western
balkans are looking to us
with the same sense of purpose
of course every country must follow its
own path but we should not be afraid to
unleash the power of europe to change
people's lives for the better as it did
for my country
[Applause]
finally we are
gathered here on europe day
during the year dedicated to youth
in the seat of the european parliament
in strasbourg
there is nowhere more symbolic
of the power of democracy of the power
of europe
to take the next steps
together this is the moment to answer
europe's call this is our time thank you
good afternoon i'm camille gerard
i joined the conference when i was 16
years old
and for me the word that describes this
adventure is hope
when i'm 65
in 2070 i'd like to be able to say to my
grandchildren that many of the positive
changes in europe emerged from this
unique exercise in 2021
their grandmother
went to the stage
together with prominent leaders
who showed a great sense of
responsibility and made every effort to
change europe in the interest of all its
citizens
let me now introduce my co-citizens
constantinos andrea dakis from greece
and camilla jensen from denmark
they are here as representatives of the
european citizens panels
[Applause]
dear europeans
during
this conference since the first
phone call which surprised us with a
proposal to take part and the many hours
of debate with other members in these
rooms of the european parliament all the
way through until today
this path
has been unique for us citizens
but it's also been a process of great
responsibility
it's
a feeling of great responsibility that
the members of the panel have and that
is the main reason why this conference
has exceeded all expectations
let me describe
two of the conclusions that have emerged
from this conference firstly i would say
that the citizens of the european union
have shown respect
for the fundamental values and
principles of the european union
secondly
perhaps more importantly for the leaders
of the european union there is a need to
review
certain elements of the treaties so that
the european union
can
move forward can be more effective and
flexible when it comes to taking the
decisions that are necessary to tackle
the various problems that arise
what we're requesting
is a stronger
europe
we're asking for more europe
given what i've seen over the last eight
months in the european parliament i
firmly believe that the european union
has the strength that is necessary to
achieve
what has to be done thank you very much
and let me give the floor to camilla
[Applause]
[Music]
taking part in the panels
has been a trip
through many different landscapes
and one of them was the landscape of
hopes and dreams when we were asked what
do you do you want for the future of
europe
and the second landscape was that of
utopia because in dreams everything's
possible
i recall a citizen who said that she
wanted to see a lift in every building
in europe that's obviously utopium but
then we moved on to the third landscape
dialogue and it emerged clearly that
what she wanted
was social security i.e access to
assistance for the elderly wherever they
may be
from
there
emerged a position
on social security and a guarantee for
assistance for the elderly right across
europe and that's an example of how
dreams
utopias
can all become clear proposals with
clear messages
however you can only act on the basis of
the knowledge that you have
european
citizens
have now
provided
this knowledge it's
written down black on white
we've
provided
precious knowledge
and now it's up to you
to take responsibility for what we've
done
for what you've been given
there is now a historic possibility so
seize the opportunity with both hands
thank you
[Applause]
i now have the pleasure of introducing
the president of the european commission
mrs ursula fonda lion
you have the floor man
we need
to think about and plan for
a united europe as if it were possible
to create it
immediately every day
we need to reject the ideas of those who
put everything off until tomorrow
if things are genuinely possible
we can start to
implement them today
prime minister costa carr antonio
but most and foremost
my dear and fellow europeans
this very special day of europe
i could not think of any more fitting
way to start than by using these words
of ozula hirschmann
for those who do not know her story
ozora hirschmann was an architect and
builder of today's free and united
europe
she resisted the rise of nazism in
berlin
in the early nineteen thirties
she shaped the future of europe on the
island on ventina
in the 1940s
she pioneered women's rights all across
europe
the courage of her actions and of her
convictions
helped to make europe what it is today
and i start with this picture
because for europe
the memory of our past
has always framed our future
and that is all the more important at a
time when the unthinkable has returned
to our continent
russia's flagrant attempts to redraw
maps
and to rewrite
even the most tragic parts of our
history
have reminded us of the dangers
of losing our grip on both
our past
and our future
on living in a perpetual present and
thinking that things can never be
different
that there cannot be better ways of
doing things and even worse
that things will always stay the same if
only we do not change
that's so wrong
standing still
is falling back
but this conference
this conference has shown us
that europeans are determined not to
make this mistake
you you have told us
that you want to build a better future
by living up to the most enduring
promises of the past
promises
of peace
and prosperity
fairness
and progress of a europe that is social
and sustainable
that is caring and daring just like
ozola hirschmann and all those who went
before us
ladies and gentlemen
this conference has spoken clearly
and i'm delighted to see so many of you
here today
through your 49 proposals and more than
300 measures
you have weaved and crafted a vision of
a europe
that delivers on metal and what matters
most
that helps to make everyday life better
that is not confined to one place
but it is it is at your side when you
need it
on every day priorities such as the air
we breathe
or the food we eat
the education that we give to our
children
and the houses that we bring them up in
it is a vision of a europe that pools
its strengths and capacities and
diversity
to tackle the biggest challenges
from climate change
or nature loss
to pandemics
or security in our region
a europe
that has a stronger capacity to activate
and uphold its values and the rule of
law
a europe that is able to provide for
itself
in vital areas
from energy
to
food
from materials
to medicines
from digital ships
to green technologies
a europe that delivers unique social
protections and benefits all the way
through these major transitions
ladies and gentlemen
i want to address every single one of
you
who took part in this conference
your message has been well received
and now
it's time to deliver
that is what i promised when i stood for
election in this very house two and a
half years ago
and together we have proven
that we can do just that
with the powers that already exist
even amidst the pandemic or war
whether procuring billions of vaccines
for citizens across europe and our
neighborhood
or kickstarting the economy after the
pandemic through next generation eu
whether setting an ambitious and legally
binding path to climate neutrality
or setting rules of the game in the
digital world
or supporting small businesses to retain
their staff during the pandemic
none of this
none
would have been explicitly foreseen in
the treaties
but it was possible
and we did it together
because europeans expected their union
to step up
so
next month already
we will set out what is needed to bring
your proposals
to life and respond the best we can
in some areas
your proposals give us a push to speed
up work already ongoing
for example on the european green deal
or on making society fairer
so that means accelerating negotiations
on the fit for 55 package
so that we can boost renewable energies
that we can save energy
and finally wean ourselves out of fossil
fuels it has to be
and it means ensuring that our proposal
on minimum wages
becomes law
so that work pays for all
in other areas we have already started
the work
you have asked
for the health working group for example
proposed creating a european health data
space
which would facilitate the exchange of
health data across borders
well
my commission delivered last week with a
proposal
and in the next weeks and months we will
bring out proposals
you have been asking for
for example restoring our nature
or cutting down waste from package
or banning products
made by forced labor
from entering our european market
on all of these upcoming ideas
we will look closely at your proposals
so that we can best cater for what you
have been asking for
the point is
there is already a lot we can do without
delay
and that also goes for those
recommendations which we will which will
need us to take new actions
so to make sure
that we follow up swiftly
i will announce the first new proposals
responding to your reports
in my state of the union address in
september already
[Applause]
but my fellow europeans even beyond this
there is a need to go further
for example i have always argued
that unanimity voting in some key areas
simply no longer makes sense if we want
to be able to move faster
or that europe should play
a greater role for example in health
or defense
after the experience of the last two
years
and we need to improve the way our
democracy works on a permanent basis
i want to be clear
that i will always be on the side of
those who want to reform the european
union to make it work better the point
is
you have told us
where you want this europe to go
and it's now up to us
to take the most direct way there
either
by using the full limits
of what we can do within the treaties or
yes by changing the treaties if need be
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen dear fellow
europeans
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself in order to
keep improving people's lives
those are the words of david sasoni
a great european who stood here
a year ago together with you dear
antonio costa
to launch this conference
we all miss him dearly
and i have a very special place for him
in my heart today
and i feel pride
that citizens from every corner of
europe have brought life to his vision
of a vibrant and modern modern european
democracy
we saw it in the national citizens panel
such as those held right across france
and we saw it in the european citizens
panels from dublin to natal natolin from
florence to maastricht
it connected men and women
who have never engaged with europe
before
different stories
different languages different identities
but one shared future
to build on
you have proven
that this form of democracy works
and i believe
we should give it more room it should
become part of the way we make policy
and this is why i will propose that in
future
we give citizen panels the time and the
resources
to make recommendation before we present
key legislative proposals
because democracy
because i'm convinced that democracy
does not end with elections conferences
or conventions
it needs to be worked on nurtured and
improved every day
we saw it in the grassroots events held
right across europe
whether debate debating biodiversity in
varna gender-based violence in lisbon or
democracy and subsidiarity in budapest
and we saw it
indeed in the image of linda
the young mother
we saw earlier this day speaking about
the future
in this very hemi cycle with holding her
baby born halfway through the conference
ladies and gentlemen
this is the image
i want us to celebrate on the 9th of may
an image far more powerful than any
military
parade and debate going up and down the
streets of moscow as we speak
and i want
and i want this image to remind us to
never ever take for granted what europe
is
and what it means
europe is a dream
a dream that always was a dream born
from tragedy
but today
that dream shines brightest not only
here in this historic place
it shines brightest in the hearts and
minds of the people of kiev and kharkiv
of odessa and mario paul
it shines brightest in the courage of
those families and young people
bunkered down in subways and basements
it shines brightest of those mourning
the senseless mindless atrocities of
bucha and in european and in every
ukrainian village and town struck by war
and it shines brightest
in the eyes of all those young
ukrainians who have found refuge in
europe a home away from home
those people my fellow europeans young
and old
are willing to fight and to die
for their future and for that dream of
fuel
that dream that always was
that dream that must always be
so i want to finish
with a message this morning i had a
video conference with president
zielinski
and he wanted to virtually hand me over
his answers to the questionnaire
of the commission for the accession
process he has applied to
it is more than 5 000 pages he hand it
over to me
and therefore i want to give a very
special message to our ukrainian friends
and families
the future of europe
is also your future
the future of our democracy
is also the future of your democracy
77 years ago
war in europe was replaced with
something different
something new
first a community
today a union
it was the day when the future began
it is a future that we have been writing
together ever since
as architects and builders of europe
and the next page dear ukrainian friends
is now
being written by you by us by all of us
together slava ukrainia long live europe
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is nicola moravec
i'm from the czech republic i'm 16 years
old
i'm the youngest participant in this
conference
the
word that i have chosen to sum up this
conference is game changer why
because this history this conference
will go down in history
together with kami and matush
we're amongst those who will remember
this even in 2090
and now i'd like to invite doreen neesh
from belgium and stephanie harting from
germany
to share their experiences with us they
will be speaking on behalf of the
national panels
[Applause]
again
dear attendees
dear european fellow citizens my name is
doreen nice i am
23. i come from belgium
and i'm actually a professional brewer
but
i'd like to sum up this conference as
normal european citizens from various
backgrounds coming together to work
together on our common european future
as a belgian representative
my experience began in brussels where
together with 49 other
randomly selected citizens we spent
weekends working on the proposals
and in parallel throughout europe
national and regional events were
organized
to the same end
and then everything came together here
in strasbourg the citizens from the
european panels the
27 member state
representatives
and presented their european ideas and
the level of ambition was very high
everybody wanted to make this conference
a success and
that has led to strong quality
recommendations being made there were
many overlapping recommendations but
there was also a lot of discussion
and the diversity of views and diversity
of backgrounds that we came from were
all a positive
aspect and in fact was one of the
strengths and is one of the strengths of
the european union
i cannot accept now that this conference
is coming to an end
i refuse
to see our proposals
as some kind of finishing line where
everybody is cheering enthusiastically
because we've passed the finish no we
have to implement this in practice we
mustn't see this as an end or a finish
we should see it as a beginning
where we all build our european future
together thank you very much
[Applause]
dear participants
dear citizens of europe
the
proposals of the plenary could not be
clearer
we need a europe that is capable of
action we need a sustainable just and
independent europe in order to
rise to the challenges
that the european union is facing
we citizens
have participated in all of the panels
and events of this european uh
conference on the future of europe
we've worked hard and we've established
great
recommendations
we have argued but we've pulled together
and found compromises and finally we
managed to unite because
agreeing on one common line is more
important than trying to force through
your own individual or national position
speaking with one voice in unity that is
the great strength of the european union
especially as we see now in the context
of war in ukraine
and
what we have created here
i think is something that the
politicians can reflect uh
let us continue the successful dialogue
on the
of the future of europe and open a new
page in european citizens participation
we have given you our recommendations in
full confidence that you will address
these and implement them soon please
don't disappoint us long live europe
[Applause]
and to
conclude today's program it's my honor
to ask mr emmanuel macron president of
the french republic
to take the floor
[Applause]
i have bad news for you
i'm going to give a speech
but i have good news for you
i'll try to repeat not what has already
been well said
before i took the floor
madame president of the european
parliament dear roberto madame president
of the european commission de ursula
prime minister
of portugal dear antonio dear
co-presidents ladies and gentlemen
ministers members of parliaments
my dear fellow citizens of
europe
world peace can only be safeguarded
through creative efforts
that
reflect
the threats
that threaten us
these were the words of robert schumann
on the 9th of may 1950 on the
contribution that a vibrant europe can
provide to civilization
are more relevant than ever these
creative efforts
correspond to the times we live in
and today
are more necessary than they were
in the past
as you quite rightly said war has come
back to our continent and a time when
people in europe the ukrainian people
are fighting for their freedom
it's
now the time where you european citizens
members of parliaments
commissioners
europeans
citizens
you have achieved
an unparalleled exercise in democracy
unparalleled in our history and in the
world this vibrant creative europe
europe based on actions you're that
europe's representatives and its
artisans here in strasbourg in this
european capital
so close to our hearts
the choice of the french people means
that i can stand before you today to say
that france will not step away from the
task
in front of us
because france has resolutely chosen
europe
by voting as it has to give
me a new mandate to build up a stronger
more robust more sovereign europe
[Applause]
the europe that we're celebrating today
is one that we decided a year ago
collectively
to move into a new stage
with president david cecily who we're
all thinking of today you were quite
right all of you in what you said
and it was under the portuguese
presidency dear antonio and i would like
to also
welcome the portuguese prime minister
who's attending this today showing
continuity and the importance of this
whole exercise
launched
a year ago in a different context
in strasbourg the capital of
european fraternity in the parliament
which
pays homage to our most precious value
which is democracy it's a new stage an
unprecedented democratic exercise in the
union where we're not
bringing europeans together in a spirit
of confrontation
to try and find simplistic options but
to think together about what the future
of europe could be which is what you
have done and it's unprecedented you've
been fully involved at a time of
historic challenge
in
creating
a intelligent debate looking for
solutions
some people want those solutions to be
applied immediately others feel this
will take time
but all of them will feed into the
europe we're building today and for the
future on the 9th of may freedom and
hope in the future
have the face of the european union
it's on behalf of this freedom on behalf
of this hope that we support and will
continue to support ukraine
its president vladimir zelinsky and all
of the people of ukraine
what is our goal
faced with the unilateral decision of
russia to invade ukraine and aggress its
people
to ensure this war concludes as soon as
possible to do everything to ensure that
ukraine will survive russia will never
win
preserve peace on the rest of the
continent of europe and avoid any
escalation
for this war to come to an end we've
adopted unprecedented sanctions
to
make it difficult
to finance the war in russia to support
ukraine we've mobilized
military financial humanitarian
resources like never before and we need
to step these efforts up to ensure we
have an effective response when it comes
to food security and we will continue
this
so that justice can speak we will fight
against the fighting and the impunity
for the crimes that have been committed
in ukraine
we are not though
at war with russia we are fighting in
europe to maintain the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine for the
return of peace to our continent
and it's up to ukraine only
to decide on negotiating conditions with
russia
our duty though our duty is to be by
ukraine's sides to obtain a ceasefire
and then peace
and then we will be there
when it comes to rebuilding ukraine as a
part of europe always
because when peace returns to european
soil
we will have to
build new security balances
and
together
we must never give in to
the temptation or
to humiliation or a desire for revenge
because we know
how much that has ravaged the road to
peace in the past
so in the name of this freedom of this
hope
uh that we have uh addressed this task
this uh
unparalleled uh new breath of democracy
that you have undertaken and you've all
said it in your own words
you've all contributed to this work
which
is now an obligation for us as you say
what we have today is not
the end it's a kind of a semicolon it's
a it's a pause
in this process which we will take
forward
uh the president of the european
commission has uh promised to
attentively study each and every one of
your proposals and i would like to thank
her for that
and we have another meeting together in
september as you have heard
on behalf of the presidency of the
council of the uh
european union and as representative of
the french presidency i promise that
this will not be a mere formality
this
will be a process which i am
sure will lead to
practical and strong concrete proposals
that will benefit the people of europe
because this conference must not stop
here
[Applause]
i
am convinced
and this conviction is is reinforced by
all the surrounding circumstances uh
my conviction is that crises should not
turn us away from our agenda many of
your proposals
can be adopted without institutional
reform but they remind us of the
importance of our agenda to protect
climate biodiversity health quality of
our food a fairer more inclusive europe
a europe of equality between men and
women
a europe
able to defend itself
a europa solidology that defends its uh
values everywhere
many very uh concrete proposals have
been made by you and we wish to ensure
that we draw all the necessary
conclusions from this in our future
meetings of the council and i commit
myself to that there are also two uh
demands which i want to stress in
particular one is for
the independence
and effectiveness of europe without
which democracy cannot be legitimate
and so these
imperatives are the lessons that we draw
collectively from the crises that we
have just been through that we are still
going through
independence and effectiveness
more european independence and
sovereignty this is what we need
in all of the the crisis that we have
been through
europe has been putting itself together
and we
are reminded by your proposals of the
agenda set out
by our european leaders of uh
in strategic independence the versailles
agenda the financial crisis that we went
through 10 years ago the pandemic the
war in ukraine show our weaknesses
and
our vulnerabilities the
the lack of ability to respond quickly
enough
so a europe that is mistress of its own
destiny uh free in its choices open to
the world
we want to be
a partner
but not to be dependent so we need to
remain open without being dependent on
others that is a condition for
continuing our european project and our
democracies
you have outlined some of the avenues
for us to follow
the areas in which we are going to have
to work over the next weeks and months
when it comes to defence to to invest
more the need to identify the
capabilities that we need
to develop the industrial sectors that
we need
to
prefer for a potential future areas of
conflict at sea in the air in space
to protect
those countries on the border of the
european union who are faced with
with a new challenge with a new threat
which has transformed us over the last
few weeks this is our duty and
all we are saying today will become a
dead letter if in the next
weeks and months we are not able to
render our
capacity credible
our capacity our ability to defend
ourselves
in particular on our eastern flank
and
when it comes to the environment you've
rightly said
we have to
move out of fossil fuels in fact the war
it requires this
of us as well this actually feeds our
climate agenda
the need to be uh independent
and to make russia face its
responsibilities the war in ukraine and
the desire to uh
get out of our dependency on russian uh
fossil fuel means as we to move further
and faster on climate change we need to
invest in nuclear energy renewable
energies we need to
be energy efficient
sober in our use and
help
european citizens face the hike in
prices
we
need to become an uh an environmental
power with our
goal of achieving carbon neutrality and
also we have to
uh
regain our food uh
sovereignty we are destabilized by the
war in ukraine the
food supply chains are disrupted so we
have to ensure that we have the capacity
to produce enough food to defend our own
food security in food sovereignty but we
also need to define and reevaluate our
strategy visa via the rest of the world
if we want to avoid famine and
geopolitical instability on our borders
and uh tragedy throughout the euro
throughout the mediterranean base basin
that is our duty as europeans
and also democratic independence
and information independence this is
something that you stress
rightly in the proposals that you have
put forward you have
begun to show us what we really are
which is
a citizens and democratic power and this
is something that makes us unique in the
world this citizen's power is something
that we have to keep alive defending the
freedom and integrity
of the information that is exchanged in
our territories on our soil defending
the integrity of our democratic
processes in
and defending throughout european
territory democracy and the rule of law
this is what
we realize all the more from the heroic
combat of our ukrainian friends how
precarious democracy is and freedom is
so we have to rebuild these through new
commitments
[Applause]
our
independence and sovereignty
uh the preconditions of our freedom
and
the next
main point i want to stress is the need
for effectiveness the ability to respond
to crises with strength
and speed
and do this decisively as democracies
remember
just two years ago
just a year ago
remember
what we were hearing
we had some people
saying that it might be better if we
were an authoritarian power in order to
respond to uh the pandemic that you know
the chinese and the russians were going
to be quicker to impose vaccination but
what do we see
open societies democratic
transparent uh processes
in our national parliaments and in the
european parliament that europe
in that context was able to become a
health power
without
treaties with without texts
guiding the way we were able to
build a response
a unique uh novel response in the face
of the pandemic
uh binding together uh science uh
democracy and effectiveness
managing to produce a vaccine on our
soil becoming the
biggest
vaccine manufacturing
part of the world
while keeping our borders open
exporting and showing vaccine solidarity
that's what europe is and that is the
europe that we should be proud of a
europe of democracy of open and free
science and of effectiveness these
things go together
so this is the choice that we have to
continue and if i look back over the
last 15 years
faced with the economic and financial
crisis we were too slow to respond
portugal and many others in greece
suffered the consequences
we were divided
we
relapsed in
national responses
we didn't come up with a collective
response
and
we weren't working together to cope with
this crisis that we had imported from
across the atlantic
but the response of the european central
bank with the famous saying whatever it
takes
those words pronounced by mario draghi
whatever it takes and in the face of the
pandemic and now in the face of war we
have shown
that we can be different
confronted with a pandemic with unique
decision
in june 2020 to create a new budget uh
uh pooled borrowing a response a novel
response for europe borrowing money on
the financial markets in order to invest
in our european priorities and in the
face of war for the first time we
decided
to mobilize the european peace facility
to help ukraine defend itself and to
fight in a way that we have never done
before so let us be proud of these
choices that we have taken to be
effective without which
we wouldn't be here today
discussing this together
so this strength
yes i think a round of applause for
europe
[Applause]
so the challenge you face us with is to
be
just as effective
in times of peace and without a crisis
decoder so we have to decide quickly uh
together
investing massively
in the right things not leaving anyone
behind
that is what it is to be european so
faced with this we also have to
reform our texts
that is clear and
i'm forced to say today that one of
the avenues for this reform would be to
convene a convention to revise the
treaties
that
is a proposal by the european parliament
and i approve this
i'm in favor of this
it would mean that we would have to work
hard on the basis of all your work and
all your proposals to define
clearly what our objectives are because
you have to
start a convention a constitutional
convention to know where you're going
so you you've given us a very strong
remit
a strong framework
so
in the coming weeks
we can
prepare the ground
seek
agreement on all sides i'm in favor of
this institutional reform and
i would like us to be able to discuss
this with the necessary
courage
at the next european council
[Music]
[Applause]
this
will mean making progress to
make things simpler so
moving forward
making more use of qualified majority
voting
for our main public policies
we should also continue to make progress
and to define ways of showing more
solidarity clarifying our aims and
objectives and the objectives for all
our institutions setting objectives that
will help us to keep europe together
growth full employment
our climate objectives
where
our rules were designed decades ago
and were based on
objectives which now
need to be supplemented in the face of
the historic challenges that we face
now
full employment
growth
carbon neutrality
social justice
these objectives must be at the heart of
the aims of our institutions
[Applause]
finally opening up
these for these reforms
also
means
providing legitimacy to democratic
control
deepening this unprecedented democratic
adventure and continuing these
democratic innovations
as we have done through your work and
i'd like to
thank the president
for having already taken a clear
commitment to that just a few moments
ago but we know we need to go further
our election rules our rules to appoint
our representatives our monitoring rules
our rights of initiative
the right of initiative for the european
parliament all of that should be at the
heart of this future convention
[Applause]
i firmly believe
that we can undertake this
work and i think we can be effective
i think that
sticking to these
environmental economic
and other goals mean that we will be
effective and this will be a way of
keeping our europe together because
without these objectives we will no
longer be able to persuade
our citizens that the european union
protects them and enables us to move
forward
now obviously not everyone will
necessarily
agree but we shouldn't worry about
differences
these have always been fertile for the
european union
and they
have never been excluded
they're part of what we do and they
exist the euro schengen etc but i've
been struck
during recent years
how as to how the will to stick together
as a union of 27 means that we move
forward and stick together
we the heads of state and government for
example never manage to meet as the
eurogroup
we
are the only co-owners who can't meet as
co-owners of a building we have to
invite the whole street we're worried
about being more ambitious and it's
always the same thing from the euro to
schengen and we're wrong on that
because
these
this this grouping doesn't exclude
anyone but what it does is enables those
who want to move faster to bring the
others with them in their slip stream
rather than making things more risky and
holding back
i know that there are concerns
when it comes to differing speeds but
they already exist we need to converge
we shouldn't be excluding
but we also
shouldn't let the skeptics and those who
are most hesitant hold us back we need
to ensure that europe can affirm itself
as a power
and this
differentiation open to all of us which
is faithful to our history and
the ambitions launched by our founding
fathers by jack the law for our europe
are important and this is a condition
for us to be ambitious and effective
[Applause]
to
conclude
let me go back to the context
i know that my proposals wouldn't be
complete if i didn't respond to this
point that emerged from your proposals
now the war in ukraine and the
legitimate
aspirations of the ukraine
like those of georgia and moldova who
want to also want to join the european
union mean that we have to rethink our
geography and the organization of our
continent
and here
with the same sincerity that you've
conducted your work
i want to say
that
ukraine because of its struggle and
because of its courage
is
already
a member
of europe of our family of our union
[Applause]
but even if we will give it to give it
the status of candidate country tomorrow
i hope we move forward towards accession
rapidly
but
even if we were to do that we all know
only too well
that the
process for accession would take
several
years in truth it would probably take
several decades
and that
is the truth
unless we decide to lower the standards
for accession and rethink the unity of
our europe and
also partially the principles that we
hold
let's be clear here
the european
union
given its level of integration and
ambition
cannot
in the short term
be the only way in which the european
continent can be structured
there are several countries for example
in the western balkans who are engaged
in the accession process
and that needs to continue
their vocation is clear
but we obviously
also need given the new geopolitical
context
to find
a way
to see
our europe to ensure that it's unified
and stable
without
making the intimacy within the european
union more fragile
we have a historic
duty here not to do things the way that
we've always done
and to say the only response is
accession
what we need to do
is open up a historic process of
reflection
given the events that are currently
taking place on the construction of our
continent
our family
is one of common values it's been
abandoned by russia
we are being shaken
by the tides of history
in 1989 president francois mitron
said
when the soviet union was falling apart
that he wanted to see a confederation of
european states
this was perhaps too precocious an idea
it included russia in this confederation
which rapidly was seen as unacceptable
for states who had just escaped the
soviet yoke
but
it raised
an interesting question which remains
how should we organize europe
in a political manner
and how can we go further than the
european union it's our historic
obligation now to respond to that
question
i think i would here today
qualify
what i'm talking about as a european
political community
this new european organization would
enable
democratic
european
nations who adhere to our values
to find a new space for political
cooperation for security
for energy cooperation transport
cooperation
to invest in infrastructure where people
could
circulate particularly young people
wouldn't
mean that you couldn't in the future
join the european union
and it also
wouldn't
be
limited to those who have left the
european union let's bring europe
together
on the basis of its geography on the
basis of democratic values with a desire
to preserve the unity of our continent
and
we want to also preserve the strength
and ambition of our integration
so this is a proposal
to respond to your proposals it's a
proposal i wanted to make to you today
now during the coming weeks and months i
will consult
and
work with
all
states and governments who are
interested in this project to try
and fulfill it
because i think this is important for
the future and stability of our
continent
ladies and gentlemen
a year ago
i said
that
my hope was that this conference would
see the return of great dreams and great
ambitions and you also wanted that to
happen
that's what you've achieved
so together
that's what we're going to do
that is europe
europe is crazy dreams
unprecedented ambition
and then
the collective ability to build
compromises which sometimes seem
laborious
and which are the language of europe
constant translation
we need to
act in a strong manner move fast and
dream big
these words don't only belong to the
united states or china let's make these
words our own let's maintain the spirit
that wouldn't exist
without the unique nature of europe
our europe
is
a unique continent
major
celebrations are carried out
by everyone speaking their own language
and having what they say interpreted
and we also have our own universe which
is music european anthems
so this path
which
we started here in strasbourg
i think
traces
a strasbourg desire for a united
democratic
and ambitious europe
we need to be faithful
to that idea all of us together you can
count on me
i see the key
thank you
[Applause]
i would like to thank all of you for
having joined us today on this
day of europe for this event that marks
the end of the conference on the future
of europe this is the beginning of a new
story
the words that linda wanted to share
with you to describe her adventure with
us the word was unbelievable
we all count on you
decision makers and european leaders to
show the citizens of europe that
something unique and significant has
just occurred
this event is important for us
and for future generations
we thank you
and all of those
who have contributed to make this
conference such a success
i would like to wish all of you a very
happy europe day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
know
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so